one of the real questions that we are
going to answer merely by observing
the American political landscape for the next I
think in the next few months, it will become clear
is whether the sparks of a Republican
civil war that we saw two months ago
will turn into a fire. And there are sort of two
possible paths forward. It's conceivable that
right wing media and the Republican Party will
realize, whoa, we are in real rough shape. Trump
lost the House for us in twenty eighteen. Trump
lost the Senate for us in twenty twenty. Trump
lost the White House for us in 2020. We have
nothing. So we have to unite. We can't have
a Republican civil war where right wing media
and elected officials are on opposing sides.
And even within the Republican Party, there could
be a civil war between people like Mitt Romney and
people like Lauren Bobo Bobert or Marjorie Taylor
Green. Right. So there's a number of different
civil wars that that could take place. The
alternative is that there is a Republican civil
war where one side of the Republican Party accuses
the other of not having stood behind Trump enough.
Of being willing to compromise with Joe Biden,
whatever, and that we see a civil war develop,
Sean Hannity earlier this week signaled that he
is at least willing to foment this civil war,
apparently turning on Mitch McConnell and
threatening that he at the time he was the
Senate majority leader. Now he's the Senate
minority leader, thanks to Democrats taking
control of the Senate. Take a listen to this.
Mitch, I will give you an A plus on getting
constitutionalist judges on the bench and great
on judges. But frankly, it looks like it's time
now you're going to go along with all of this
nonsense. We need new leadership in the US Senate.
You can represent the people of Kentucky. You're
showing basically right now that you're the king
of the establishment Republicans that frankly
have always had and remain having contempt
for President Trump and more importantly,
the 75 million Americans that voted for him.
Americans want somebody that will
fight for their values and principles,
not scheme behind closed doors with your buddy
Chuck Schumer for every Republican in the Senate.
So much like with Maria Bartiromo, Sean Hannity's
direct line to the president ended yesterday with
the inauguration of Joe Biden. He knows Biden's
not going to take his calls like Trump did.
So Hannity wants to stay relevant in some
way. And what's going on here is that Hannity
believes he's still the decision maker and the
influence peddler. Now, he may be he may find
a way to maintain that role, even though
he doesn't speak to the president anymore.
It would be really great for the left to have a
battle between right wing media and Republicans
that that is only good for the left. And it's
just what Joe Biden needs to get going with
some momentum. Republicans so busy with infighting
that they are unable to obstruct the things that
Joe Biden wants to do to clean up Trump's mess.
And one other funny thing, you know, by Hannity
talks about maybe we need new leadership in the
Senate. There is new leadership in the Senate
because Democrats won the Senate. And Hannity,
of course, means new Republican leadership.
But the new Senate leadership is Democrats
all together. And this is going to be very,
very interesting now for people saying that I'm
somehow being hypocritical on this. I'm not.
I have said before a divided Democratic Party
with infighting is bad for Democrats and a
divided Republican Party is bad for Republicans.
The difference is I want the Republican Party to
be divided because it will be bad for them. I
didn't want the Democratic Party to be divided
because it was going to be bad for the left wing
movement. And so I'm consistent. Infighting is
bad. I just am going to benefit from Republican
infighting and thus I'm fine with them doing that.
Send me your thoughts and we'll continue
to monitor this over the next few days.